(jaunty music)
- What's up guys?
This is Angelo, I'm a Buzzfeeder
and I'm about to head out
into the streets of New York
city to see if New Yorkers
can really tell fact from fiction.
And everybody knows New
Yorkers are known for being
able to smell bullshit a mile away.
So I'm gonna put them to the test.
(lively music)
- Um, I am standing in Staten Island.
- I love in Washington Heights.
- Upper west side.
- Okay, and you think that you
got a pretty good bullshit detector?
- I mean, pretty good.
- What about like pop culture?
Are you kind of up on movies and stuff?
- I know more 90s stuff
than I do stuff today.
- Alright.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm
just gonna give you three
facts, two of them are true,
one of them is made up.
And you just gotta pick which
you think is the fake one.
- [Woman] Alright.
- Here's your first fact.
Snoop Dogg is a voice option
on TomTom GPS systems.
Star Trek had the first
interracial kiss to be
broadcast on television.
And third is that Bambi is
America's favorite movie animal.
- I think the first one is false.
- [Angelo] You think that Snoop
Dogg is not a voice option
on TomTom?
- No.
- I just don't think that Snoop Dogg
would do something like that.
I think that's crap.
- [Angelo] You think it's Bambi?
- I don't think Bambi
is America's number one.
- [Angelo] You don't?
- Nope.
- You're incorrect.
So, Bambi, according to
a study, is America's
favorite movie animal, sorry.
(lively music)
- First fact.
Sylvester Stallone wrote
the original Rocky script
in three and a half days.
Second fact.
Hugh Hefner owns the crypt
next to Marilyn Monroe's.
And then Sinbad played a genie
in the 1990s movie Shazaam.
(clicks tongue)
- I think it's number one.
- I think it's the first one.
- I pick the first one, writing
the script in three days.
- [Angelo] You think that's false?
- Yeah.
- You're incorrect.
Yeah, he wrote Rocky in
three and a half days, man.
No one has faith in Sly Stallone.
- What do I know?
I mean, I just know Youtube.
(lively music)
- We got one more set of
facts for you here, okay?
- Alright.
- Your first fact.
In Forrest Gump, Kurt
Russell reportedly provided
the voice of Elvis Presley.
Remember when Elvis was
there, dancing, and he's
teaching him how to dance?
Second fact is that Carrie
Fisher, AKA princess Leia,
rewrote The Empire Strikes Back script.
And the third one.
Johnny Depp and Marilyn
Manson have matching tattoos.
- I think it's the second one.
- [Angelo] You think that Carrie
Fisher didn't really write
Empire Strikes Back?
- Yeah.
- Uh, princess Leia did
not rewrite the entire
Empire Strikes back.
- So, let's go with the last one,
Johnny Depp and...
- [Angelo] Marilyn Manson?
- Third?
- [Angelo] You think that
Johnny Depp and Marilyn Manson
don't have matching tattoos?
- I don't.
- You're incorrect.
- What?
- Johnny Depp and Marilyn
Manson do have matching tattoos.
They talked about it in an article.
(dramatic music)
(electronic noise)
- I feel pretty bad.
Uh, a lot of credit goes
to Sylvester Stallone.
Sorry I didn't trust in you.
- I guess I have to reeducate
myself on this, you know?
- Yeah, you gotta brush
up on your 80s movies.
- Yeah, definitely.
- I wish I had a trophy for you.
Participation trophy.
- Aww, no trophy?
Bummer!
(lively music)